a pregnant Emily Blunt stunned at the  Huntsman winters war premiere Monday  night the actress is expecting her  second child with husband John Krasinski  the pair already have a two-year-old  daughter hazel have you prepared hazel  in any way for what's gonna happen does  she understand what's coming with the  baby mm-hmm  she's a bit dismissive of the idea at  the moment she's quite liking being top  dog I think you have a plan she has no  choice she has to just I think my plan  is just to tell her that this is less  about having a sibling and more that  she's been promoted and she gets to have  a worker now you know who she can boss  around you know that's that's kind of a  good tactic I think